we are now learning more about the pilot
whose deadly helicopter crash onto a
roof of a New York City skyscraper
briefly stirred fears of a 9/11 style
attack Tim McCormick was the only person
on board the private helicopter
yesterday he was unfortunately killed
when the chopper slammed down on a
high-rise near Trump Tower and Times
Square and then it burst into flames
photos show the burn debris no one in
the office tower or on the ground was
hurt in the crash New York's governor
said there is no indication of terrorism
CTM national correspondent Jericka
Duncan is outside the building where it
happened Jericka this crash certainly
unnerved people here in this city
absolutely and for good reason when you
think of 9/11 and of course for the
people who were inside and said that the
building literally shook when that
helicopter landed here that forced to
evacuate people were forced to evacuate
just blocks away from Times Square but
the question remains this morning why
was that pilot flying in such poor
weather conditions and in restricted
airspace hundreds of feet above New York
City investigators are combing through
the wreckage of Monday's deadly
helicopter crash trying to answer what
happened a massive emergency response
inundated midtown Manhattan minutes
after the helicopter came down on the
roof of the 54 story AXA equitable
building workers forced to evacuate
describe the feelings of anxiety inside
at the time you know you heard like a
plane maybe crash there were fears that
like maybe something like 9/11 happened
Nicholas Estevez was outside when he
says he found this piece of debris I saw
people roni like crazy out of the
building and people running everywhere
the helicopter took off from a heliport
along New York's East River at about
1:30 2:00 p.m. it was believed to be
headed to its home airport in Linden New
Jersey but 11 minutes after takeoff the
Agusta a109 a helicopter crashed into
the top of the 750 foot tall skyscraper
at the time the roof of the building was
reportedly the same height as the cloud
ceiling
New York's mayor says the NYPD believes
this video shows the helicopter flying
erratically after takeoff rising then
dramatically diving before it eventually
flies toward Manhattan through the
clouds it looked like very erratic
actions by a pilot in control I'm having
trouble following why he would have gone
back up over midtown Manhattan if his
destination was well to the south in New
Jersey something doesn't follow here
after President Trump took office a
flight restriction banned aircraft from
flying below 3,000 feet within a
one-mile radius of Trump Tower which is
just blocks away from the crash site the
pilot Tim McCormack was a former fire
chief in upstate New York with 15 years
of flying experience according to FAA
records sources tell our New York City
station WCBS that McCormick actually
radioed he was in trouble before that
crash and as a result of what happened
congresswoman carolyn Maloney who
represents this district is now calling
for a ban on all non-essential
helicopters flying over Manhattan Tony
Rodriguez thank you
veteran pilot former fire chief it may
be that he was trying to prevent harm in
landing on that possible but as she
pointed out the cloud cover yesterday
was very low in the city you couldn't
see a lot of the tops of the building so
you do wonder what he was doing up I
heard one report that said they thought
he was trying to avoid Times Square that
he was clearly in trouble he knew he was
in trouble and he was just trying to get
at get down as quickly and safely as he
could answer is forthcoming and
hopefully thank you very much